everyone so I'm here today to talk about
how we've scaled our data pipeline
throughout billions of events every
month and maintain a very high level
develop low variability and this is
especially in the face of third-party
api's which might go down Atimonan stoma
moment's notice so for this talk in
particular I first like to talk about
the constraints of the problem that
we're trying to solve here then I'll
talk through our particular architecture
and how we started and how we've grown
that over time as we've on board more
and more customers finally I'll talk
about how we use micro services to all
run all this infrastructure in
production and then I'll finally wrap up
with monitoring how we actually make
sure that everything is working together
so first up what are the constraints of
the problem we're solving here now i'm
going to hedge this talk a little bit
since it primarily deals with the
problems that segment solves but even
though that's the case a lot of these
lessons can be taken if you're running
an in-house ETL process or any sort of
big data analytics pipeline where you're
trying to fan the data out from one
place to another so let's make this a
little more concrete suppose that you're
running an online business let's say you
sell running shoes as part of a website
if you're running this business there
are a few different people at your
business doing different jobs perhaps
you have customer support people who are
responding to incoming tickets or people
are complaining about shipments or wine
to return certain items you have sales
people who are maybe arranging those
like really big sneaker deals you know
like the ones that steph curry does or
something like that I don't watch sports
really but hopefully that was a good
reference and let's say you also have
marketing people who whenever you
launched a new sneaker brand or a new
campaign they want to email all of your
customer base and say hey we've got
these new sneakers for you to come check
out and then finally you have analysts
who say no no none of that just give me
the data I want the raw thing and sequel
or some other data warehouse
so ordinarily if you had all these
places that you wanted to get the data
and each of them has a very well-defined
workflow you'd be using different tools
but the key insight here is that they
all want the same data in every single
tool so what you do is you dad little
pieces of code for each one's you get it
into each cruel but that creates a
problem right you end up with a tight
coupling problem where you say hey
whenever I want to add a new tool I have
to add a new piece of code so how do we
solve a tight coupling problem well Joba
people will tell you I had a layer of
abstraction boom but in our case that
layer of abstraction is actually just
segment right it's a single API that
sits in the middle and you replace all
of this custom code into each individual
API with a single line where you send
data to our API and we'll fan it out
into all these other tools and then once
you've decided to set the data you can
configure them with the flip of a switch
so for this particular problem we need
an API that can deal with thousands of
incoming requests per second it has to
be able to track things like clicks
adding items to your cards ad
impressions anything under the Sun and
then it has to fan those out into tens
and hundreds of thousands of requests to
these external third-party tools
additionally the system is a little bit
different than some of the other systems
you've heard about today and then that's
it that it needs to be real time we're
not talking a batch ETL process or a
MapReduce job a lot of these events that
come into other tools actually perform
triggers based upon real time data say
when a user signs up or add something to
their cart so we want to make sure that
these things are delivered roughly under
10 seconds but anywhere up to a minute
is reasonable we're not talking about
dealing with finance or stop trading
data here and lastly the system needs to
be able to scale out in the face of
hundreds of unreliable AP is now there
are a few golden metrics that we use to
kind of hold ourselves to the standard
of deliverability here and these are
what all use throughout the talk is kind
of a benchmark for how well our system
is for
forming the first one is delivery rate
this is the rate at which segments can
deliver messages to third party AAP is
now you might be wondering why on earth
with us ever be under a hundred percent
right well and there are a few reasons
for that the first off is that these
partner api's could go down at a
moment's notice so we're dealing with a
pretty hostile environments the second
is that a client might unbeknownst to
the partner be trying to send more data
in then the partner can actually handle
in which case why there have to back up
limit or eventually drop the message the
second one is the end-to-end latency
this is the point from when the event is
actually created to when it enters the
third party tool and like I said before
we want to keep this below 10 seconds on
average though anywhere to a minute is
probably reasonable and then the last
one which isn't quite as hard quite as
much of a hard and fast metric is our
data fidelity we want to make sure that
if we're sending data through that it
doesn't get lost and what I mean by that
is say if we're sending an email through
we want to make sure that that email
ends up in all the different fields and
all the different third-party tools
rather than dropping at one point or
another so now that we have a good sense
of the problem that segment or really
any data et al pipeline at a large
company is trying to solve I wanted to
dive into the system architecture in
particular I wanted to talk about where
we started and then talk about a few of
this lessons that we've learned over
time while scaling out the system so to
really set the scene here I wanted to
share a picture from our first office
and so a little bit hard to see in the
light but calling in office is slightly
generous this is one of the apartments
out of which segment was born and as you
can see here our walls were covered with
white boards we had four twenty-dollar
desks from costco we had about a 30
second commute walking from our bedroom
to our living room and over the course
of the time we had actually spent a long
time building other products now it
might be unbeknownst to most of you but
we spent about 18 months
building products that were totally
unrelated to what we do today over the
course of that time we were starting to
fail and really run out of money so as
you might guess when we launch this
first version of segment in about a week
and a half scalability wasn't quite the
top of mind so here's what we built it
with and these were all technologies
that were using at the time and some of
them we've still kept and some of them
we've moved off everything was node
where we were able to work with
JavaScript both on the server and
clients at able enable us to prototype
really really rapidly we're using
RabbitMQ as our messaging layer in the
middle we used amazon from day one
working on top of their ec2 and VPC
infrastructure and then we use [ __ ] and
Redis as our primary data stores and
here's a rough architecture diagram of
exactly how that all fit together as you
might guess we presented an API to
clients that was all written in node the
API I would process incoming events and
for each one it would check out given
their API key does this belong to a
project that we're aware of if it does
and everything checked out we then fan
it into RabbitMQ which SATA is our
reliable queueing layer and from there
rabbit delivered it to two places one is
our integration workers and the workers
actually deliver messages into each
third-party tool and the second is our
archiver the archiver is just a bunch of
flat files split by a particular project
which gives us a really good backup in
the case that anything goes wrong with
other parts of the code and that's
sitting on s3 so for the first part of
our scaling we had to scale this data
collection API oh man this is really
hard to see well I'll annotate here so
after about three three months post
launch we are doing a handy 80 request a
second which really doesn't sound like
much though it felt like a lot to us at
the time and we were running about 3 a
p.i instances and over the course of
that time we've scaled pretty
significantly to about 13 to 15 thousand
per second of incoming messages per day
at the moment though we're only running
rough
30 api machines to actually handle this
load so the question is oh thank you
that is beautiful so the question is
what did we actually do in order to
scale this system out and what lessons
did we learn over time well there are
three things that we did to actually
scale this API the first is running
changing from rabbit to NS q as our
queuing system the second is moving from
node to go and the third is making the
edge entirely stateless and I'll talk
about each of these in turn so first
moving from rabbit to NS q for those of
you who are familiar with rabbit rabbit
is a brokered queue which means that
individual rabbit nodes are tracking
exactly what sort of messages are being
processed and this worked okay for a
while but after a certain point we
started getting running into problems
dealing with more messages than one
rabbit instance could handle so we
started coming up with a complex
sharding scheme to split different
rabbit instances but over time this drew
to be really operationally complex so we
eventually ditch the whole thing and
moved over to NS q which is a
distributed q by default and I'll talk
about the architecture for that in a
second the second thing that this did
was actually remove the amqp protocol
and for any of you who have actually
tried to implement the amqp protocol or
look through the drivers for it it is
nuts there's believe it or not a
seven-way handshake in order to set up
the connection to this queue which is
great if you need really really high
deliverability guarantees but it makes
implementing drivers a huge pain so we
actually built our own driver for NS qjs
running a node and it's worked pretty
flawlessly honestly for the past two two
and a half years and finally n SQ has
been simple and rock-solid to deploy
operationally how simple in rock-solid
you might ask four hundred trillion
messages rock solid and we're passing
through roughly a hundred thousand per
second right now and the great part is
for most of this we haven't had to do
anything with n SQ we simply boot more
of them and because they're distributed
they all take care of themselves so how
does this architecture actually work
well n SQ distributes you what they call
an NS QD node and this is simply a
process which you publish to and what's
called a topic you say hey I want to
record that there's a quick coming in
and then you have various channels which
represent the fan at now the key here is
that this n sqd is all one single
program so if you're publishing to it
you're writing for this program and that
program will first write to memory and
then spill over to disk it means that if
you're running different consumers the
consumers each connect to each single
one of these NS q DS and so what this
looks like in a network topology is you
have a bunch of an excuse running
independently none of them have to know
about each other they simply just
publish their metrics and their look up
addresses to the central set of look up
servers which operate in a similar
fashion to [ __ ] config servers and then
you have consumers which can connect to
either a subset or a full amount of NS q
DS it doesn't really matter how many
they're connecting to so long as you're
able to drain all these messages from
one to the other additionally NS key
recommends that you actually co-located
each n sqd with the publisher so here
you can see our revised set up for the
API and you can see that we have
individual nodes that are running and we
have individual and sq instances running
right alongside them that then consumers
will pull from and i'll talk about why
this was a significantly improved change
for our scaling in a second but even
with this setup we still ran into some
issues now if you're like me you might
have guessed hey I'm dealing with a
bunch of website data chances are
everyone's going to have more or less
the same load pattern we're going to
have some spikes during the day weekends
are going to be a little bit more light
evenings probably not that much traffic
well I was dead wrong here you can see
metrics from nine different projects on
the segment platform you can see that
their load patterns very pretty wildly
you have some which go down during the
day you have some which go up at night
and you have some which are really noisy
because they're batching every minute or
so what ends up happening is your API
servers get
with very varied load and this can cause
problems especially when the load is big
now here's what would happen when we
were checking individual problems with
our API servers we'd see a single
message come in that was relatively big
say a few hundred kilobytes and then
we'd see the entire sliver server start
grinding to a halt like we were seeing
what should have been a 20 to 50
millisecond response time grow at a 15
to 20 seconds and we were digging into
this and trying to figure out what was
causing these issues and eventually what
we discovered was the event loop totally
blocking now for those of you who are
unfamiliar with node node operates in a
single threaded event loop model and
kind of like Nettie and the balance a
little bit different and supports multi
threads node essentially schedules some
sort of work to be done and as long as
you're running synchronous code the
scheduler work will continue just
letting you run that code synchronously
until you tell it hey I'm ready to be
done and you can perform some io now at
that point you push more work to be done
on to what's called the next tick of the
event loop and from that point forward
the scheduler continued running until
all of those have finished it will read
the IO and then perform the next batch
of work unfortunately in our case we had
some things that were very very
synchronous one of these is just parsing
JSON JSON and node is really quick to
parse the v8 parser is very highly
implement or optimized but you can still
run into problems especially with big
JSON bodies additionally we'd often
clone these requests and part of our
functions to make sure hey that if I'm
modifying some sort of nested field it's
not making it back to the original
request or other functions that might
deal with it but this runs into problems
say for example that your load balancer
hypothetically or York you use
heartbeats in order to detect whether a
server is alive or not what would happen
when we were dealing with this very
desta JSON and basically blocking the
event loop the server would disconnect
from load balancer and disconnect from
the queue that was probably
too meaning that we basically drop the
data and nothing would get through so we
did two things here one of them is that
we actually switch this outer edge layer
to use go now I'm not saying that you
can't do the same exact thing and go
it's just a lot harder go by default
provides you with a scheduler between
different go routines and of those most
things that you do within a single go
routine will end up yielding to the
scheduler at one point or another the
second is that we actually split out
this tracking API edge here on one
condition it'd be totally stateless now
in our case messages come in we do some
basic validation around JSON and message
size and then from there those messages
are immediately queued but the number
one thing is that they don't have to
talk to [ __ ] they don't have to talk to
the rest of the system they don't really
have to talk to anything and what's
great about this is that even if you
have some sort of problem further down
the line like a network partition or a
zombie apocalypse no matter what the
rest of the infrastructure or this edge
layer will stay up and we'll stay
processing messages it means that if we
need to we can scale to multi-region
very easily we can scale to more and
more of these edge servers without
having to worry about the rest of the
infrastructure knowing that those
messages will just continue to queue and
sit on their local n SQ instances so to
wrap this part up we've scaled the API
by making these edge notes stateless
though I'll caveat this that this only
works if you control the client as well
otherwise you're basically forcing a
poor API on to all the developers who
are building on in we've used n SQ for
simplicity and reliability and we've
used go to achieve better parallelism so
remember we started with this initial
node API I was checking a database we
move to something that's a little more
scalable in terms of our data collection
but I still haven't talked about the
ingestion and fan out layers right how
do we get messages from our system into
all these different systems now in our
case these are actual third parties but
you could imagine them at a
really large company these being
internal teams which actually just have
different guarantees on their AP is so
for scaling the fan app we're going to
first talk about how we changed around
our cute apology how we decided to
abstract everything and how we same
leery try in the face of these failures
and discuss a few of the concerns around
those so let me talk first about
queueing now basically from day one I'd
always view skews as giving you
flexibility or right let's say you're
running a service and the service has
the ability to either go down or it
processes requests in seconds or minutes
even it doesn't get overloaded with any
sort of like batch of messages because
you have a queue sitting in front of it
right they give you a little bit of
leeway and how you're actually running
these services so needless to say we run
queues everywhere because they provide
us a lot better fault tolerance but what
I hadn't really considered until
recently is that ques also give you a
form of scheduling and let me talk about
what I mean by that let's say you have
some unit of work to be done and say
you're writing an operating system
scheduler you could represent that as a
queue where you're giving work to each
individual core and if you're doing this
naively you can just take work off of
the front of the queue give it to an
individual core take work give it to the
next one take work give is the next one
and you get actually get the highest
overall throughput this way in terms of
total work but the problem is that you
end up not being the most fair for
certain things that are more require a
higher priority which is the whole
reason that processes end up having
priority and it's something that these
queuing systems don't give you by
default so instead what if we could
break up the work and actually logically
separate cues such that we basically
bend them up by priority or complexity
so we know that for all these green
tasks here they can be accomplished
really quickly while the blue and grey
tests might take a little bit longer but
they won't block the green tests so
let's slide that back to our example
here
initially we started out with just a
single queue where we have these
integration workers which were sending
events to Mixpanel sending events to
enter column google analytics maybe
these hundred other tools the problem
though happens when one of these tools
goes down in a way that causes each
request to timeout now we want to be
relatively generous with how we're doing
timeouts here because we don't want to
try and abort the request too early so
we give maybe a three maybe a ten second
time out to each of these tools to make
sure that we're actually doing our best
effort to deliver the message but the
problem happens when one of these tools
gets low right then the integration
workers are just spending all their time
waiting which is disrupting the fairness
for every other integration so what do
we do well we changed around the queuing
topology here instead we created a cube
per each integration that gave us better
fairness between them and meant that
integrations could fail independently if
you look at this graph of queue depth
here you can see that per each
integration some of them will go down
and some of them will have spikes at
various times some of them will even
just be hey with various batches of data
but they won't affect one another
because we have individual queues for
them as well as individual workers for
each one the fact that we have
individual workers means that we can
also scale the throughput of those so if
we want to say sends 50x the data for
Google Analytics we can run 50 X the
containers of any other integration so
our n system looks a bit more like this
and I'm simplifying here since there are
a few hundred services running inside of
segments but this can give you the gist
there's a tracking API which is
stateless forwarding to an internal API
and then that forwards into individual
accuse which workers take off and send
to these third-party a tools now besides
queues the second thing that we learned
very early on is too abstract everything
and I'll talk a bit more about what I
mean by that now micro grounder Ian
often says if you're building a hundred
and fifty of anything you're probably
going to want to err on the side of over
abstraction because at that point
you don't want have to change something
at 150 different places and so that's
why we split things up we keep every
single integration that we run in its
own repo actually so that there's
individual commit logs individual change
logs and a single release doesn't batch
together updates from multiple
integrations additionally we've created
a factory to actually generate these
integrations which is totally
configurable via our own dsl and for
those of you who aren't familiar with
javascript i'll get to exactly how this
works in a second but essentially what
you can do is create immigration just by
passing it a name you tell it which
channels it's enabled on and what
endpoint it's supposed to hit and then a
few of the settings that you need one of
the best things we did here as well
comes down to this mapper layer the
mapper basically takes a certain JSON
input and says hey I'm expecting this
call to end up with a certain JSON
output which is in a sense what you
really want to do with all these
different data transformations right you
want to say hey I'm going to glue this
one layer layer a two layer B and
eventually I'll get my format from one
point to the other and the holy grail of
this is that eventually we could build
some sort of visual interface or store
these dynamically maybe even on the fly
such that we are able to dynamically
generate transforms from one service to
another without doing hardly any extra
integration work additionally because
this stuff is all abstracted into a core
integration prototype it means that
writing new integrations is really
simple pretty much all you have to do is
say I want to hit this particular
endpoint with this particular query
string or maybe this particular payload
and then all the error handling is more
or less handled for you but on the
subject of error handling I couldn't
talk about only that without talking
about our retry behavior and why it's
important to talk about retries is these
integrations fail all the time if you
think about say you're running a service
and say it goes down maybe once a year
that's pretty good up time in terms of
nines right not too bad but in terms of
the services that we're dealing with if
every service goes down on average
once a year that means we're dealing
with downtime once every two days so we
have to be really smart about how we
deal with all of these retries and do
our best effort to actually deliver data
so we do two things when it comes to
retries will retry any time the server
indicates there's a problem on its end
these are all just 500 statuses and then
we also retry for rate limits in the
case where say a particular customer
tried to batch too much data into a
service well back off and then send it
later additionally will try for any sort
of network errors for most of you this
should be pretty evidence since network
is definitely not reliable but in our
case it's something that whenever we
experience a timeout network disconnect
couldn't reach a host dns failure will
then actually send the data again at a
later point and when thinking about
retries there's two key metrics to keep
in mind here the first is how long
should you wait to deliver a message
which is honestly an open question in
our case we decided we're going to wait
up to 30 minutes to deliver a message if
after 30 minutes it's no good then
chances are that that the API is down
for an extended period of time secondly
you can consider the attempts to deliver
a message how many times am I going to
try this API in order to actually get
the message across in our case we
decided five times is probably about it
right if after that point in time we
drop five messages then chances are that
is just poorly formatted for that API
and there's something else going on
that's causing it to 500 what this looks
like here which is relatively simple
it's just an exponential back-off
strategy the key point is that we also
add a little bit of jitter roughly plus
or minus thirty percent duration in the
case of rate limits so that way if a
customer is sending in data and all in
one batch it immediately gets rejected
we're able to then spread out the
delivery of their messages I
to talk about how this is all abstracted
basically all day but I'd like to switch
gears here and talk about how we
actually run this stuff now by using
different micro services and the key
points here that we've basically adopted
microservices everywhere like most of
you we've used docker to get better
isolation and we've done a lot to ensure
that these are easy to boot now I wrote
a blog post a while ago about why
microservices work for us and most of
discussion out there i'm around
microservices revolves around scaling
teams often is the case where you have a
software engineering team that's now
fifty a hundred people and you need to
figure out how you can actually split up
those teams so they're not all working
on the same code base and stomping on
each other's feet additionally people
talk about micro services as being able
to scale certain parts of your stack
let's say we want to run more Google
Analytics workers if that's only one
thing that we can run 50 of those
whereas if we're running total
integration workers then we have to
scale those up even though not all of
them might be doing the work I'd like to
add a third point that's not often
discussed as far as microservices go and
that's visibility it turns out that most
of the tools out there all center around
the idea of hosts processes and network
and the problem here is that often times
it's very hard to figure out what's
going on in a really big app just using
those tools I mean what was the last
time you like fired up top or H top to
figure out what exactly a 10 or 20,000
line program was doing you probably
don't that's the whole reason that flame
graphs exist in fact but let's suppose
now instead of running that 10,000 line
file you're analyzing a hundred line
file that's running as part of its own
process in a docker container what you
can see here is its immediately evident
that this service has a memory leak and
it has a go routine leak but it's very
clear to figure out exactly what's going
on here because there's only a hundred
lines in the file since the service
itself is so small we can forget about
it most of the time and then when it's
having issues we can pinpoint exactly
where problems are occurring
which is what the nice thing that
microservices have given us additionally
we split these micro services and what
we call different clusters so each
cluster is separated by concerns so in
addition to monitoring at the service
level we get a little more insight into
what particular hosts are doing of
course I couldn't talk only about the
clusters without explaining what exactly
the services look like so this is a
typical segment service and I'll explain
each of these in non AWS terms as well
route 53 is a waw SS dns service this is
indicating which load balancer we should
point something at say if we connect to
auth service segment local will register
a DNS entry for it additionally every
service will have its own load balancer
and that load balancer will point to
particular instances or containers on
that are running on those instances that
register themselves with the load
balancer what this means is that we
don't need any form of service discovery
there's nothing like console or at CD
running here and admittedly there's some
performance overhead from that and it
doesn't work in all cases say if you
have a driver which actually needs to
connect to multiple instances for
redundancy or failover but it does work
fairly well for most of our apps I can't
be out this that this is only this will
only work well for you if microservices
are actually easy to boot right
otherwise now you have two problems you
have a bunch of services and it's really
hard to orchestrate and run them do this
we use terraform for those of you who
haven't used terraform it's pretty
similar to amazon's cloud formation
service it basically describes your
infrastructure in the form of JSON or
terra forms HCL I guess hachey corp
configuration language but basically
what this does is it provides minimal
work for a programmer who's trying to
create their own micro service in their
case they just say which cluster they
want it to run on the name and version
of the docker container and then give it
some memory and CPU and boom we're off
to the races in terms of actually
creating this thing and running it in
production additionally we built
significant tooling around actually
deploy
knowing these so that deploying them is
easy fast and safe whenever you get
pushed to a repo github will trigger a
build in circle our CI tool and from
there it will actually build a docker
image whenever the CI tool passes from
there we can deploy be a slack or via
CLI tool which updates the image that's
running in ecs amazon scheduler and then
it pulls new versions of the code down
from docker hub in this way it makes
running new containers very easy and
safe it means that we can roll back
pretty much instantly since all the old
versions are also tagged in docker hub
additionally it means that we can run
the same versions in stage as well as
production lastly I'd like to talk about
monitoring how we ensure that the system
continues to run in production now I
like to say that the more surface area
you have the more visibility that you
need into that system in our case it's
really true so since we have 150
different external touch points which
could possibly fail yet fail at any time
we require a lot of visibility and
really invest in this religiously in
terms of the metrics that we record and
so we keep track for every integration
delivery rate success rate of that
partner API end-to-end latency and any
top errors that we see coming in and
like I said we have a lot of these
metrics here but giving us splitting
each of them out into their own category
gives us the ability to really figure
out where problems are happening and
find them quickly additionally we keep a
roll up of these so we can see for a
particular integration or for the system
at large exactly what's happening with
any key area and we built our own
service toolkit to automatically record
most of these metrics they could be
things like the duration that it takes
to process a message the CPU time the
number of go routines the memory all of
these things should be things that the
programmer gets out of the box when
they're building a service from day one
so as far as the big lessons for scaling
our data pipeline which hopefully you
can use for your own internal data
pipeline or if you're building your own
ETL platform if you control the clients
you should try and make the edge as
stateless as possible this is something
that honestly I hadn't considered was a
good idea for the longest time I was
wondered about why Google Analytics or
these other large tail providers so
basically 200 on everything until I got
to the realization that none of them
care about supporting third-party
clients really for then they have a
single client and their number one
concern is preventing data loss so if
your system operates under similar
constraints I'd recommend make the edge
stateless make it just a bin for
incoming data and build clients around
that so that people can easily send data
to it the second one is that ques not
only defined service boundaries where
places can fail but they also define
scheduling and rate limiting so it's
worth thinking about when building your
queuing topology do I want everything in
this queue to have the same priority or
do I want to actually split it out and
to possibly different workers or
different topics third you want to have
micro services and workers if they can
provide great visibility and scalability
only so long as they are easy to boot it
requires a significant investment on the
infrastructure side but it's paid off
immensely for us in terms of providing
better visibility into what the running
system is doing and finally the bigger
your surface area the more visibility
and metrics you need to provide this is
something that we've learned the hard
way by not having good visibility into
the system and anywhere you can't ask is
the system working what's going wrong
right now how many messages in my
delivering is a case where you should
record stats and metrics I'd like to end
its talk with a few open questions about
what's next and what things were
considering since this system itself is
far from complete the first one is just
finding more search of fairness and what
do I mean by that well right now where
we operate with
at the integration level right messages
come in they get grouped into different
integrations or third-party services and
from there none of those will affect
each other we can spin up different
workers and essentially that system is
fair where we don't operate with
complete fairness comes down to how
customers are sending data let's say a
really large customers start sending a
giant batch of data it could mean that a
smaller customer actually has to wait
for their data to come through at all so
we're considering various options there
around either encoding the jobs within
the queue format or coming up with some
sort of internal scheduling system built
into the queue itself that would provide
good fairness on keys passing through
the queue the second idea that we kicked
around is moving over to Kafka like I
said n SQ has provided incredible scale
out and very very low operational
overhead but where it loses out comes
down to replication like I said before
each n sqd is actually operating
independently and since these are
operating since these are backed by EBS
Amazon's scalable hard drive system we
don't worry that much about losing an
individual node except for the case
where there's some sort of n SQ problem
that writes bad data Kafka would take
care of this replication for us in
addition in addition to giving us crazy
throughput third we'd like to create a
standard micro services toolkit that are
hoping to open source in q3 or q4 of
this year ideally this would give you
everything that you need out of the box
like metrics reporting logging error
handling everything if you're coming and
creating a new service such that you get
all of these other visibility pieces for
free the last one I want to ponder is
the idea around custom data transforms
right now we control all of the code
that's running in the system but what if
we didn't what if customers who could
support code or partners really anyone
I'm aware that this is a total isolation
and security nightmare especially given
the current state of running them as
docker containers but if we could find a
way to either give people an interface
like lambda does to run custom
JavaScript functions or run custom
containers we could potentially scale
out the system to support arbitrary
integrations with customer data so in
that I'd like to open it up for
questions and thank you all for coming
today thank you questions rather than a
long few days going once okay this is uh
probably could be handled by customer
support as we use you guys but since I
got you here so we're just recently
moved over to using segments and looking
at your stack because we were using
another provider who just accidentally
lost the day of data which was not great
so my question is with your stateless
edge what is your fallback for a failure
at that level I understand you have
you're queuing with the the NS q but
what if I don't know the data center
gets hit by a natural disaster or
something yeah so currently all the NS q
nodes are backed by EBS which provides
pretty good guarantees in the case of
failure since that's all stateless what
we could do say if an entire region gets
Newt is then we can move to another
region pretty easily because we have all
that code we have the instances and we
can spin up the infrastructure basically
at the drop of the hat for then it's
still persisted yes yes oh sorry yes it
is stateful but only local to the
machine yo le
how's using docker hub in production bin
for you guys we use them as well and
they go down all the time yeah we also
have that problem is the short answer
and eventually we plan to move to the
Amazon container registry which should
provide a lot better like both security
guarantees and reliability because we
have had problems as well pushing and
pulling to them and for the most part it
ends up not being that big of a deal but
yeah occasionally when our developers
try to push a build then we run into
issues what else
yeah you didn't really talk about the
redshift integration that you guys have
I just wanted to expand on it a little
bit yes and so for those of you who are
unfamiliar recently we added support for
warehouses to our platform and what
happens here is well basically bunch up
all this data on an hourly basis that is
where the archiver comes in it will
upload to s3 unbend by each particular
project that is for and then from there
we'll run an ETL step where we actually
load it into the redshift cluster so I
didn't talk about that as much since
it's a relatively recent and B and we
don't have quite the volume of traffic
going through there since it's running
on an hourly basis and per each customer
it's only dealing with their redshift
instance for some of these partner api's
which are receiving like thousands or
tens of thousands of calls per second
but it is something that uh yeah what do
you want to know Joker's like is there a
custom API like so like I've got my own
events that are not going to mix panel
or to Google Analytics like can that be
right at through segments into redshift
yes yeah basically anything that you
send in to our API and we'll batch up
and then put in your into your data
warehouse whether that's red ship for
postgres